[Music]
good afternoon welcome to saw cast
number four and today
we are honored to have with us marcus
witt
who ran recon and hatchet for us
and he was with command and control
south
and uh we are honored to have marcus
join us today marcus welcome to the show
well i'm glad to be here and let me
correct you you did i i want to recon
hatchet force oh you're one of them yeah
and so for i wasn't a brave soul like
you were
just young just a commoner yeah there we
go and so for our first time viewers saw
cass are interviews with uh men who
served in sag during this eight-year
siku war and it would had the highest
casualty rate during the war of course
we didn't learn that till after the war
far after the war
but uh we ran missions across the fence
in cambodia laos and some into north
vietnam and the missions varied from
uh bomb damage assessments to wiretaps
prisoner wars snatches picking up enemy
soldiers because they're good intel
and today we've invited marcus because
he's another member who served in sog
and uh
so marcus let's just start off with how
you're introduced to sod because i
thought when you landed in vietnam you
had orders to go to a traditional a camp
and just for again for our
listening and viewing audience um
when
during the vietnam war we had many a
teams which was a 12-man green beret a
team and they would have different camps
many along the border to in an effort to
monitor
enemy troops coming in to deal with
local activities in the country
and there were i don't know over a
hundred at one time during the peak of
the war in vietnam and the secret war
ran from 1964 to 1972.
so you landed in saigon or
cameron yeah cameron bay is where i came
in uh i had actually come from
um
oh i almost lost my mind i actually came
from first group on oaky was that right
i was assigned a first group out of
training group uh
and uh went into okinawa the first group
b company uh was actually assigned to
the halo team although i never got the
halo but hello
oh i guess i need to say that don't high
altitude low opening there we go uh and
uh so i i uh
did a lot of parachute packing learned
how to to pack the shoots uh i do did a
lot of jumping but didn't do any actual
uh halo other than uh uh the a couple of
practice kind of things but wasn't
official right uh so uh i i did that for
about seven months oddly enough
one of the first assignments that i was
myself and there were three radio
operators that came out of bragg
altogether myself uh
michael thomas
excuse me thomas michaels and
[Music]
mike blackwell
all three of us came out of training
group went to first group and were
assigned i don't think mike was in b
company but anyway we were all signed
together and one of our first training
missions with
first group was learn how to be bus
drivers
yeah it was the craziest thing that uh i
had ever been a part of but anyway it
was designed because of the hurricane
season was coming about and we were
supposed to be able to pick up all the
troops wherever we had them and and
transfer uh those folks to various
locations to high ground yeah out of
that hurricane so anyway
uh after doing that did get to do a
couple of things uh i got to do the
taiwan mission
short one got taiwan wings
uh and also tai
uh so i was fortunate to do that but
then uh i just got tired of the uh
bureaucracy i guess you could say so i
volunteered for uh nam
uh and uh mike and uh
michael thomas eventually followed
uh i think i was the first one to go but
uh
landed in cameron bay like anybody else
there was only two green berets on the
plane that we were on
uh myself and a staff sergeant i'm sorry
i can't remember his name but he had run
at ccn
uh and we got off the plane and were met
by a sergeant major in a jeep i don't
know his name i'll be honest with you up
front i'm i'm terrible on names don't
worry about the names of stories with
councils i don't i don't remember
remember folks names real well uh
sometimes i forget my own but
uh anyway we were mad on the runway and
[Music]
i had heard from this staff sergeant as
we flew over the ocean about some of his
exploits
in sog and he said
you know you might not want to do that
and i said well i've got orders to go to
an a team so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
worry about it at all right right uh
we uh hit the tarmac and sergeant major
meets us and said uh where you guys
going
and both of us said well we're assigned
to whatever 18 he was going to and
whatever 18 without he said well i've
got a choice i've got you a deal for you
you have a choice
we need people and sog and you can
volunteer for sog or you're going to a
light unit your choice oh the legend
yeah so i looked at this e6 i'm an e5
he's an e6 and
i said what do you think you've been
there and he said i ain't going to leg
unit and i said well i didn't want to go
either but
uh anyway so anyway long story short we
we volunteered and i don't he went on i
think he went back to ccn uh i went to
ccs
as a radio operator and that was
the first assignment at ccs was in the
talk as a radio
right there let me just update where we
are because in the early part of the
secret war there were six fobs one
through six
and uh
fob five was at uh
bami it f1b6 was honok town that at the
end of 68 they consolidated and they
they moved the personnel from fob6 to
ban me to it
kantoom became so badly to it then
became ccs command and control south
cartoon became ccc command and control
central and up north they pulled
together fob 3 and 4 and 1 combined them
at danang which had been fob4 and so
when you land there are three major uh
bases and each had launch sites so you
land there and take it from there so you
get stuck in the comma bunker for a
little while yeah i'll get stuck in the
commonwealth bunker uh they were real
short on radio i mean and i'll say this
on my own good radio operators
uh
because we you know back then we were
using one time uh cac pay ads we were
using cw and for our viewers this if you
explain what the one time oh okay that
was a uh
coated pad it was
uh oh i don't know half inch thick
tissue thin pages
uh and i can't i believe it was 30
groups of five letters each
so there were uh if i remember right
thirty that sounds like so stuff for
government okay uh and
um you would encode these and it was a
pretty easy uh process once you learned
uh that ba equaled y
uh and uh anyway uh so you would use
that
uh in your daily upsec
uh you would be given a certain uh page
to use and that's the page you would use
and uh if you were compromised then of
course you wouldn't you would uh they
would do away with that entire book but
anyway it's uh
we used the cac pad to encode or any
messages that was sent cw and then
people on the other end had the same
code that they had the same page that we
did yes in fact a number of us got good
enough that we could
uh
put the co i mean put the message across
and
uh actually record the uh message in uh
think about that a bit we encrypted it
and then decrypted it at the same time
really yeah oh i never got that good
well
anyway uh so
i got stuck in the talk for several
months yeah uh and then we they an
operation went out uh a first company
there were there were two companies as i
remember sure first company was yards
second company was cambodians and i was
assigned myself and ben brown were
assigned uh to go on an ex exercise on a
mission
mission uh that ran out of boot op uh
along the cambodian border and boot up
was the launch site i'm sorry yes
was a was the launch sign sure there was
also a launch site at quan loy uh that
uh
folks went out of a lot of the the teams
went out but this was uh if i don't i
don't may not have the right time period
but this was a situation where we
actually first company was involved
inserting
three
recon teams in other words we took a uh
mission that ran the border right uh we
were out 30 days in fact okay yeah
it was a long one uh i'll tell you
another
point about that long mission in a
minute but
uh but anyway ben and i ben brown and i
split and i would go uh to boot up uh
and uh in their comment bunker right and
take care of any uh
traffic that was coming in uh with the
teams uh there uh and then we would
switch off uh after about uh a week and
and uh ben would come in and i'd go back
out so
uh
we did that for for 30 days and uh
as we walked along and there was
predetermined
uh grids
that the uh recon teams would just leave
the element
and melt into the jungle
uh and i we we i think it took four days
to insert three teams and that was their
planning because that's see for me even
for me that's a new technique that i
hadn't heard oh really yeah so
basically
even with estimated numbers so you have
three recon teams would be six eight man
teams
and then your hatchet force would be how
many other personnel well you're looking
at uh probably
i'll say
40. wow
so that's a big insertion yeah so well
you all get inserted once by air
we came in yeah we came in on blackbirds
c-130s okay
uh so and landed at uh at the boot up
airstrip uh on another time that we
landed at the boot up airstrip sort of
i'll tell you that one later but uh
anyway that was uh it i say unique it it
was that we understood it was the first
time it was done yeah where we inserted
teams uh using the hatchet force and i
don't know whether it was ever done
again to be honest with you i was never
involved in one that didn't
mean it didn't happen yeah because
you're busy with your team yeah you're
hatching for yes yeah so
uh anyway that uh
that was an interesting time and so we
get we get out
uh we i think we had about
three
uh if i remember correctly three times
at which we engaged the enemy i don't
remember how large enemy forces but
right uh of course i was uh
a large element like that they they know
you're coming oh sure yeah you can't do
that many people quietly like you guys
did
so
it was a it was still amazing to me
how well-trained the
the the original folks that were on the
the hatchet force had done with with
the yards uh because they did a good job
they really knew it yeah they knew what
they were doing and they they knew to
keep quiet and there was you know uh
noise discipline was was kind of
shocking when you got right down to it
but still you have that many people
you're gonna get noticed oh yeah
so
uh that uh that was a different end so
we come back out of the field
uh
successful mission
uh i don't remember
uh about i don't remember what happened
to the three teams i mean how successful
or unsuccessful that their mission was
but the insertions went well and we
didn't have any issues there so we come
back out and i'm
you know if you spend
you spend four weeks in the in the the
jungle and uh uh you're you're not very
clean
so we all want to get back and have a
drink of smoke and yeah and and take a
shower and i started in that order yeah
in that order
uh and so i started to head for the
shower and somebody came running over
the talk said the the colonel wants to
see you
and i i'd only met him you know i feel
like we were good buddies or anything
and i i thought well what in the hell
have i done because i
well anyway long story short somehow
during that 30 days probably near the
end my mother
had contacted the red cross
because she hadn't gotten a letter from
me
and he chewed me up one side and down
the other for not riding my mother and i
explained to if i'd seen a post office
in cambodia
i would have dropped the letter in for
him
and you can't tell your mother why you
didn't right no
i couldn't so that was a that was an
interesting time it was kind of funny
but uh that's our first i've haven't
heard that
the colonel chew you well yeah
thanks to the red cross yeah
and your dear mom oh yeah well that's uh
she was a dear mom she was concerned
about me yeah yeah so after you get your
ass chewed you get your shower and then
what's next
well i go back to talk uh then spent uh
i probably did six or seven weeks at
different times maybe more on the radio
relay site we'd take
usually about 10 yards 10 12 yards
and
usually two american radio
operators uh sometimes one i did one one
time without where i was the only guy
only american
and of course we went up on the radio
radio reel site which is a big tall hill
uh that was on west of miami or west of
ccs yeah uh between uh ccs and the and
the cambodian border
and you know communicate as best we
could
with fox mike yeah yeah yeah
so uh uh did that uh a bunch of times i
like i said i don't remember exactly the
number so are they taking you by
helicopter
no we actually walked
you went through a yard village
uh it never made any sense to me either
but we actually walked
from
uh the compound to the radio relay site
and i don't remember it it was probably
seven eight nine clicks i don't remember
exactly but i remember one night uh
myself and bill davis we were up on the
hill and
and uh
basically what we did when we weren't
communicating was we were rebuilding the
the sites you know right sandbags
deteriorate and all that kind of crap
and people some people do take a good do
a good job of taking care of things some
people don't so we'd all we've been we
were rebuilding and uh uh got evening
time and of course the yards got their
meal and we got our sea rats and we're
actually sitting in the bunker uh and
all at once
uh mortar stopped started dropping in
around us
uh and in fact
one of the tubes or tubes was actually
walking you could see oh yeah it was
walking it up that hill and so we got on
the radio and came back to
to
talk and said hey we got a problem we're
being hit by mortars and
uh
we got we need some help
and uh i don't know how long was
probably five minutes uh somebody came
back on the radio and said oh don't
worry about it it's friendly it's ours
and
people and i looked at each other and
uh i think bill was talking to him and
said i think those mortars that kill us
just as dead you need to get it stopped
somebody got wise and finally did that
oh no really yeah it was another
wonderful funny thing that's happened to
to us radio operators so
uh
interesting indeed
because the radio relay sites had a bad
history of getting overrun yeah now i
don't think this one to my knowledge
ever did it's got probe several times
but
you know i it never to my knowledge ever
got overrun this didn't get around to
the final attack but they did the
approach oh seriously you got probed all
the time so you were always
on on high alert you didn't sure
not do your due diligence in regards to
setting up security so so eventually it
comes time for the a cambodian incursion
yes uh in fact uh it was the the i guess
the one i remember the most is one when
the big red one was scheduled to go into
cambodia right and
all
you teams all the recon teams i don't
know how many were involved did all the
intel for that that incursion and just
for background
uh during the reason why there was a
secret war
was that american troops uh our
government agreed not to have any combat
troops in cambodia or laos the
communists did the same thing
however the colonists being lying scum
that they are
this ignored it amen publicly they
stated that they respected the
neutrality but they never did they tried
to and they overtook laos majority
layoffs had the ho chi minh trail that
came down
into cambodia also
and at one point in cambodia they had
over a hundred thousand troops staged
they would go across the border attack
south vietnam then go back
into cambodia into the sanctuary
so uh
years prior
many a general wanted to attack but the
politicians or somebody would not allow
them to go in finally
in may of 1970 we had the first official
inc they called it an incursion
into
cambodia by the big red one and some and
many helicopter units but meanwhile
quietly behind the scenes we had sog and
your role part of that was okay well and
and i i want to mention that uh sog did
all the intel in other words sog had
already found
uh the issues that the big red one was
going in after all the cash the the
weapons the explosives the uh
facility yes uh you guys had had uh done
the intel to find out where they needed
to go and what they were gonna find so
in fact i would
it would not surprise me and i feel
fairly confident that they knew
sog already knew where everything was
they just told the big red one you know
here's here's where it is here's where
you need to go
so uh
uh you know i mean you guys
were great you had great eyes and ears
you knew you know what you were doing in
that in that regard so anyway i don't
know all the ins and outs i know that
first company was tagged to go in
and assist uh in that mission in some
form or fashion uh i do remember that
again we were there were three of us
three americans and uh i again i'm gonna
say 20 30
um yards uh that would put on a
blackbird to go into boot up
uh and i honestly don't remember
what exactly we were supposed to do
right i know we were supposed to go in
and do something
uh we were going to get our briefing at
buddha before we went in i mean we had a
general concept that we were going in to
assist big red one
uh and the um we all loaded up uh uh
flew in the the blackbird uh it's not
one that far uh as i remember to boot up
because it's set right on the cambodian
border right uh and so uh we just
started to make our approach and land
uh at the runway and
we got ripped from the nose to the tail
51 cow machine gun just tore us to
pieces
shrapnel flying everywhere and
i i told tilt earlier that uh probably
the scariest i've been because uh uh you
have no control it's not like you can
stick your weapon out the window and
shoot back
uh plus
uh if that plane crashes you're probably
gonna die
real quick so at least with the weapon
and the enemy in front of you there is a
chance you can get away as you well know
indeed so uh anyway we the pilots which
i didn't know who the pilots were as you
wear between the uh the storage area of
the c-130 and the pilot compartment was
a black curtain and you couldn't go
there right uh i guess i we did we
didn't have the the clearance to do that
certainly i didn't
uh but anyway we got shot up and the
pilot did was able to get control of the
plane pull it back up learned that the
hydraulic system
uh to the wheels uh were was knocked out
and i can't remember
whether it was the nose wheel or the the
wheels in the rear that could be cranked
down i think it's a nose wheel but i
won't swear it was the back ones okay
i'm sorry it was a back one yeah uh and
we could do that but they couldn't get
the nose wheel drip down so the pilots
flew
clear across vietnam in the uh i don't
know what altitude but they gain
altitude
uh and uh cut the engines trying to get
the wheel to come undone so we bounced
from basically boodop
uh to
a cameron or or
i don't know or thompson or thompson
whichever had the longest runway and i
may have been tons of newt
uh but anyway of course not not only
being scared [ __ ] let's uh
i don't hope that was okay to say that
it's okay uh but uh uh you know that uh
didn't make my stomach any feel any
better or anybody else's uh and were any
people wounded for new rounds going
through the aircraft the the screw chief
took uh
a round
uh if i remember i was in the leg
uh but i won't swear to that and i took
a piece of shrapnel in my leg
which
you know that woke you up yeah it woke
me up made me feel really good
but uh anyway so uh we fly across uh
they do whatever
uh they do for a crash landing at don
sinoot
and we go in on our belly
uh sparks flying everywhere and uh
our e7 and i can't remember his name
uh he was uh
i guess acting for sergeant really you
might say yeah uh he uh
told us that once we landed
that we were to to put a perimeter
around the aircraft uh and that we were
not allowed to allow anybody on that
plane unless they were sog
uh so we landed uh and uh
we all got out formed the perimeter and
i don't know who the general was but a
three-star
uh air force general decided that he was
going to come out and
see what was going on with this aircraft
which i guess i don't blame him you know
yeah somebody lands on his
uh his airstrip with a crosstalk and
somewhat spectacular he he may yes
uh and uh he made a big hurrah about
getting on it wanting to check it out
and uh the e7 told him he couldn't get
on the plane and uh
the general was rather insistent but
sergeant turned around to all of us and
said lock and load we did
that general turned around left you did
and he did it yes that's exactly right
that was fantastic oh what a great
moment time so
i i don't remember what happened
to the yards and the other two americans
but they pulled me and tons of newt and
flew me up to play coo
and play coup is where
all of the enemy
materials that they were pulling out of
cambodia was being uh dropped
uh and i don't remember what what sog
had to do with that but we had something
and they needed a rating was one of the
was one of the refuel bases for ccca oh
for tct okay yeah uh well anyway that's
they sent me up there as a radio
operator and i was to maintain uh
communications long range into uh
cambodia uh from there from there wow so
i don't know what the reasoning was
behind it just did what they told me to
do but there's kind of a funny story
about that i i uh
of course was doing my deal and and i
had to go somewhere in a jeep i don't
remember where it was but i had to go
get something or take somebody somewhere
no i must get get something because i
didn't have anybody else with me so i'm
going down through uh the area and i
guess i was speeding
and got stopped by the mps no no
and uh of course i'm a e5 i don't have
any any signal or anything else on but
uh uh of course the mps stopped me and
and uh asked me what unit i'm with and
you know various sundry and i said i'm
sorry i can't not say i'm you know
marcus witt five four six six eight two
one one whatever was and
uh
anyway i quiet
and so uh they put me in handcuffs
and one of them drove the jeep i was
driving to to the uh command post the mp
command post and uh took me into a
captain
and you know we had our little uh card
that said get out of jail for free i
don't
i never knew before whether it actually
worked uh but uh
uh we got in there and the captain again
asked me name rank still number what i
was doing who my unit was how many of us
there were and i didn't say anything and
i just handed him the card and i don't
know who he talked to you know you dials
the number that in saigon
and whoever it was
i never had another problem again
because they dressed the captain down
and he turned to me afterwards and they
said take the handcuffs off
escort sergeant witt
to wherever he needs to go and make sure
that he has no delays whatsoever so i
got the jeet and left
that was that was kind of funny too oh
yeah so anyway uh
as as i think we know the yeah the
mission turned out well
got lots of stuff i i remember uh
uh forgetting about the chinook and the
electrified hook and getting the ship
knocked out of me for
grabbing a a sling load full of ak-47s
so
uh it was it was a very interesting time
then so you got this [ __ ] knocked out of
you but yeah if you don't ground
yourself and grab a chinook hook right
there's this i guess it's static
electricity that goes through it it will
knock you it knocked me off
i was standing on a
that's what i was they brought in a
sling load of weapons right and we were
hook up concertina wire okay and i was
standing on the roll of this big roll of
constantino wire and i was supposed to
hook it up on and i grabbed the hook to
go this way it was a bad mistake it blew
me clear off the thing so really yeah
it'll knock the trap out of you i don't
know whether it still does do that it
doesn't it still does okay according to
reliable sources
so anyway
so you so okay how much longer are you
in sag after after the incursion and
then uh i left uh you know i did the the
radio relay sites and i did another
couple of mission things with uh uh
first company
uh
i left at the end of october of 1970.
uh
i was queried about
re-upping and
after my experience with the promotion
board i said screw you i'm not
interested
i had discussed
before with the the uh radio uh
uh supervisor i remember as sfc nelson
was our nco and then we had captain
potter wasn't harry or him henry wasn't
henry uh but uh
both of them were not inclined to let me
go
to
uh
our rt school go to recon but uh
so things just
didn't work out yeah i would have
wouldn't mind staying but
uh i was just not really happy so so
this is your first tour of duty with the
army so when did this first tour duty
begin for you because the earlier
discussions
you said you had interesting
walking maybe just how
do you get into the army in the first
place a little bit of your background to
get up to that point where then you get
into the army and then we'll come back
and take it post sod post your first
tour of duty with uncle sam's army well
i i
grew up in a very rural area uh both
mostly cattle and oil wells uh in osage
county oklahoma and tornadoes and
tornadoes yeah tornadoes hail uh but uh
my dad was a uh he worked for phillips
trolling company in the oil field and we
had a small ranch so
i went to a high school that
my graduating class was 53 so very small
wow not not as small as some but very
small yeah
i was my mother was a teacher at the
time and
so
i always went to school didn't skip
class but
i was i was a good athlete i played
baseball football and basketball for a
couple of years i wasn't a very good
basketball player but i was a good
baseball player and a good football
player and
i was
offered a scholarship to go to a junior
college to play football and uh
uh
then received a letter from oklahoma
state university
saying basically that uh they'd like me
to walk on and if i made the team i'd
get a scholarship
so
i grew up an osu cowboy uh my my dad mom
both went to school there that's where
we went for game days uh you know we
were very involved in the college uh uh
college football in oklahoma that's yeah
everything else is secondary
yeah well i mean they had another
college too right yeah you played
oklahoma university that's what it was i
wasn't sure about the name yeah so
anyway i decided to go to college and
walk on oklahoma state and uh
probably wasn't a good idea because i i
i came from very rural small high school
uh you
you know there wasn't a whole lot to do
uh get to stillwater and there's bars
and there's beer and there's women and
and that's what i did i i
i didn't realize you had to go to class
you had to go to class yes yes i had to
go to class and uh
my first semester i was after it i was
put on probation
and second semester it just went worse
we have one thing in common another
thing in common
life on probation in college
i was bad and i
it's funny out there when i was uh uh
and i played football yeah but you know
i was no star i mean i i don't want
i lettered and that's it you know yeah
so you were there you did it yeah yeah i
was a safety and so uh anyway i would on
on fridays when it wasn't football
season uh i would go home
uh and it was uh to get to my house
it was probably
70 80 miles
but there was two ways you could go
and always went home and would wake up
the next morning
not having a clue which road i took
and i you know the good lord had to be
riding with me because nobody else would
uh i was i was really bad off drinking
and uh
not going to class so anyway long story
short my dad came to uh my little
apartment one day
uh and said pack your bags
you're going home so we get home
uh he said tomorrow morning we're going
to pawhuska which was the capital of
osage county
and you're going to join the army
yeah well yes and and back then what
what did we say to our parents when they
told us to do something we said yes sir
no sir yes ma'am no man i said yes sir
so i went to uh pawhuska so what year is
this this was in 1967. okay i'm sorry i
didn't even say that 66 i graduated in
uh in 1966 and and 667 was still
watering yeah 7 67
uh in the uh
fall
is when i crashed or when dad had had
decided i'd crashed enough
so uh anyway he took me to um
uh pasca i signed up i signed up for the
draft i mean i knew i was going to get a
a draft notice anyway so i i signed up
and if you remember back in those days
you had there were two
um
way or two
numbers that you could get you could get
an ra or a u.s u.s so i started out as a
u.s no kidding yeah u.s because i was
volunteer for two years right well
uh we go to now back then maybe they did
but i didn't remember being even asked
about what do you want to do in the
military it wasn't until i got to to
fort polk louisiana for basic that we
went through that all the rigor you had
the tests yes
yes you take the test and they they give
you this list of of things that they say
you're qualified for and you know i
don't have a unfortunately i don't have
a mechanical bone in my body
and i chose
helicopter mechanics no
yes and i do this i don't know why
i didn't fly i'm not a pilot you know i
don't have any clue why i decided to do
that
uh so they said oh that's good for in
order to do that you're going to have to
sign up for another year so what did
that do i became a regular army yes i
became regular army and i was one of
three regular army guys
in our platoon
in basic training
so one day near the end of our eight
weeks
uh it was raining that dog and of course
fort polk is
well
you know
yeah
so uh it was raining like a dog and they
were going to the range and they called
the three ra guys name out of first
formation and said you guys are going
you're not going to the range today
you're going to jungle
warfare
orientation
yeah
we didn't have a clue what that was but
we knew we were going to be inside and
not standing out in the rain so that was
a good thing so we all crowded into i
don't know how many basic training
you know platoons there were right
at that time but this was a huge
uh auditorium and it was full
so i don't know how many of that was
uh a bunch of bunch of folks
i'm kind of surprised so but 1968 was it
was a year the highest
number of uh american troops in vietnam
okay well this is 67 so that would have
been fair you're building up to it yeah
yes sir so so we go into that and out
from the stage walks
a guy that's got these
shiniest boots i've ever seen
you know jump boots oh yeah has the his
cochrane yes has the uh
jungle fatigue starched oh my god has a
green beret on his head yeah and he was
the first
enlisted person or really army person
that didn't start out with you mfs
so i thought that was pretty good i
thought he's a good guy you know so he
gives a spiel about green berets
and uh tells us that uh you know you got
to take a
physical test you got to take a mental
test if you pass those you know you
we'll send you fort bragg and all that
anyway long story short i i did the deal
did good
uh
one of very few out of that entire
auditorium that got to go yeah to begin
and so they sent me to fort
leonard wood for 12 bravo learn how to
blow things up mainly
and then i went to jump school
when i was at jump school they were
filming
the jump part i wasn't in that but right
they a jump part of of uh the green
berets the movie
star john wayne yes
so uh and i i
it's
i remember seeing it at bragg you know
seeing the movie and oh yeah laughing
about some of the things that took place
and then you get to nom and find out
well it really doesn't happen that way
but uh uh anyway i i
uh went through
uh got the sf training uh was going to
be a medic
went through 91 alpha really
went through 91 alpha and i don't
remember when that decision was made or
you know all i know is i went to 91
alpha sure it's 91 alpha and we were
supposed to go to 91 bravo at
fort sam
uh but uh they called us in formation
one day and said it got there's a delay
of 90 days i guess
91 bravo got backed up or something and
said you have a choice
you switch ms mosses or you can pick up
pine cones for 90 days
well i thought doing something would be
picking up pine cones
so i volunteered to switch to and they
yeah you know we any of the others and i
went i don't i don't know why but i went
radio operator i'm glad i did because i
got to be good at it but uh
uh it's uh that's how i ended up at at
bragg and went through i i do remember
uh the uh
first phase we had phase one two and
three back then right uh this was in 60
let's see if we've been in 68 and 69.
uh you went through phase one phase one
uh don't i remember there was an sfc
torres do you remember torres
he was a badass
okay bad guy bad
vietnam guy okay i mean he was well
known for his
heroics jacob's folks have used words a
little bit more harsh than that oh okay
okay so we're not pc here okay oh good
i'm glad to know that
uh so
anyway uh we you know they divide you up
into teams there at the end and you're
supposed to x fill and uh you know we
can find uh through the swamps and and
the everglades or whatever that yeah
heck you could find they had you go
through but uh uh you had e and e
uh and you had to do it successfully in
certain amount of time
and uh we they dropped us off out of
medusa half in the middle of nowhere and
there was like i'm gonna say six of us
a couple of officers of course you
didn't really had options yeah a couple
officers and and uh four or five
enlisted yeah remember uh of course i
was uh e3 i was an e3 yeah much power
yeah
wow people are crazy to give me that
kind of stuff
but uh anyway i'll never forget this you
know you have to use your light
discipline yeah and
the uh one of the lieutenants yeah i
guess they were both lieutenants one of
the lieutenants lit up a cigarette no
and all i heard was this growl
coming from behind us we turned and
looked
and of course i didn't know who he was
at the time yeah before this happened
sfc torres liked to tore that
lieutenant's head off come screaming out
of the woods and just
you know annihilated him
for yeah yeah four light disciplines so
they understand it but the scary part
was he told all of us he was going to
make sure
that we had to do this again oh and i'm
going i can't do this again
i'm not gonna do this again yeah yeah so
we go he leads us and and i was so
impressed with his ability
uh i swear he could go through a brick
wall and you wouldn't hear him he was
the most stealthy man
yeah i just couldn't believe it anyway
we got about probably three quarters the
way through
and some uh trainee
lost his weapon
so they called the whole
exercise off everybody passed and we had
to go help try to look for the weapon no
somebody yeah somebody individually find
me
so that was my first experience with sf
along with sometime during that i had my
first bout with kidney stones before oh
yeah so
uh but uh it was it was uh
a great opportunity i've never been so
proud of doing anything in my life as
being able to go through sf school sure
uh you know went through phase one of
course phase two was radio opera school
right and then uh you went straight
through didn't get recycled like i did
no well no i didn't
i i was good uh i was a good liar i
guess you know faked a lot of stuff but
i got lucky i really was and i had a lot
of good uh people around me that uh we
all worked together you know right then
you came to your ftx yes
ftx that went smoothly didn't have any
issues that was a a wonderful experience
with the uh uh pineland uh sure yeah
that was great
uh i graduated from there i've got a
pine land sticker on my vehicle so is
that right university
yeah so uh anyway uh and so the last uh
you know three or four days you spend on
the phone with mrs alexander trying to
get
uh your choice assignment yeah uh i i
probably called her three or four times
and she was always gracious i mean
thinking about all of the numbers and i
don't know the exact numbers but there
was a lot of people that went through sf
training then oh yeah
and every one of them was called mrs
alexander at some point in their life as
you said you
took her candy and a bouquet of flowers
or something bottled wine bought one
her wine in the flowers there you go
went to the pentagon this is 69 for in
my case
just because you get what you wanted
yeah i want a ccn oh okay we'll see
i didn't i didn't get out of fort devon
oh okay all right
yeah you already signed you were already
in group right okay okay well i was
trying to get into group and so my first
choice was actually tenth group because
i i want to go to bath tolls and help
people across the wall i thought
seriously and we're civilian clothes i
thought yeah that's that'd be great
that's a great so that was but first and
and uh first group was uh second and
fifth was third and i got first group so
ended up in first group and we already
talked about that indeed so they'll fast
forward through your first tour of duty
you get out of the army
and this is 1971 or 70. well it's the
end of 70. and the 1970s
and so what happens here okay well you
know
of course we all know during that period
of time going home
uh
the way vietnam veterans were treated
right uh i experienced a little bit of
that i think the the biggest thing for
me
the kind of a shock really
and then i look back on and think well
maybe it shouldn't be but
was
my folks acted like
i just been had gone somewhere for
vacation and come back
there was no discussion about
how was it are you doing okay
i mean it was really odd yeah
because my but my dad never talked about
war i mean you could ask him something
because he was a tanker in world war ii
he was attacking so he knew under combat
was like yeah general pat and i guess
probably nobody talked to him about it
so
but anyway that was kind of the surprise
and then
uh you know you kept a low profile i
went back to college
and
got married
the first time and uh
money was a big deal
and i happened to be down at
gone from a junior college
i got my associate's degree and went to
get my four-year degree instead of going
back to oklahoma state because they
probably wouldn't have taken me back
uh i went down to east central state
college which is down in southeastern
oklahoma four-year school and i was on
campus and ran into
uh
one of the rotc guys and he was uh green
beret wearing his beret and the whole
bit okay any any yeah he and i hit up a
conversation i you know of course told
him about my background he said you need
to join the 12th
i didn't course i didn't know anything
about it sure and i said we never heard
about it yeah and and going through fort
bragg no not a bit 11th and 12th with
observed groups 19th and 20 were the
were the guard groups and uh so uh i got
uh uh he gave me could you explain a
little bit what the difference would be
between the reservists oh okay sure and
then you had national guard 19 yeah well
the 11th and 12th were
army reserve units right uh and of
course they were uh directly under the
president of the united states okay that
president is the only one that could
call them to duty right there was a
guard two guard units 19th and 20th
and they were just like normal guard
they answered first to the adjutant
general of the state in which they
reside and then of course
to the president if if he wanted to
activate him so
there were no guard units
sf units in our state there was a
reserve unit and it was second battalion
12 special forces group in tulsa
oklahoma so i ended up joining them uh
was an e5
made e6 real quick
i actually went into the battalion talk
initially and then i was assigned to
a211 as a senior common man and spent 10
years initially with
the 12th group uh the second battalion a
211 and then uh
i
i because of
financial things i needed to get
promoted and i was in e7
uh i needed to get promoted and get uh
you know uh
to help the family budget and so
a friend of mine in the town in which i
was living offered me an e8 position in
the unit that he was a battalion
commander for
so i left and became a e8 master
sergeant in a personnel and
administration battalion
uh so
you got the promotion yes i got the
closer uh so
that worked good and of course i i uh
uh i meant several years in in that unit
and uh several other uh reserve units
uh then i ended up uh in
um
this is during the 80s into early 90s
yes yeah there's not much going on the
army's being
rift reduced yes and and
the one the one big difference that i
saw between the guard missouri between
the 11th to 12th 19th and 20th is
the 11th and 12th very seldom got to do
anything right i mean we did some
missions along the border of mexico
uh back in the drug drug days sure and
the drugs were coming across heavy uh we
would go out there and sit on the border
for hours upon end uh if you saw
anything you had to report to the border
patrol yes exactly because of posse
comitatus yes exactly yeah
so uh but that was really about it uh
other than training missions alaska
panama you know those kinds of things
but you know but still training missions
and you're out of country well that's
true yeah yeah i mean you know you just
kind of brush over that but still like
the whole idea of packing up gearing up
you go to another country yeah yeah i
jump in usually yeah we had a lot of
jumps in the 12th i've always uh i've
loved jumping uh i would have uh
loved to be we we tried to go to halo
school for instance right we never got
to
uh i didn't get to go to jump master
school until i became csm
really uh of uh 12th group uh
segmentation 12 special force group
fort campbell fifth through fifth groups
uh no county
jump masters of course wow uh but uh
anyway i i happen to be in a usar school
as a csm i've made csm excuse me i'm
sorry sergeant major uh i was in charge
of enlisted courses for this usar school
uh that the united states army reserves
what usa are standing for
and they were responsible for doing
military occupational specialty courses
throughout the united states to guard
and reserve members
called schoolhouse the soldier
so i happened to be on the second floor
unit on the second floor of a reserve
unit and a reserve
uh uh building and the first uh floor
was occupied by uh 12th or excuse me uh
a company 12 special forces group
uh and so a company was located in
um
there in oklahoma city which battalion
headquarters was in tulsa
some 90 some miles away
so one of the uh of course i was knew
most everybody there and so would visit
with them every time we had drill and
uh so one of the guys came up to me and
said hey uh
are you gonna apply for this csm
position at second battalion i said i
don't know anything about it so they
gave me the the paperwork and had me
look at it i looked at it and i thought
well i've only been starting majors
three years there's probably not a good
chance in heck that i'm gonna get csm
but you know like i could at least get
some experience in submitting a pack
doing a packet and submitting it and
again for our listeners though the
people
in the ordinary world would know the div
between a sergeant major and a command
sergeant major and at that time
the whole rank of command sergeant major
was evolving into
uh into the formal army structure itself
and into sf yeah because sf was
beginning to grow a little bit then
finally well actually the way i've
always people have asked me that that
question the way i've always answered is
that uh
csm's command sergeant majors are at
battalion and above
so they're not in company level right
sergeant majors are
uh they can be at battalion but they're
going to be battalion and below and
these are the top enlisted personnel e9
personnel so uh i be i became uh i
submitted my packet and lo and behold as
you would figure uh i was accepted and
it was kind of shocking because i wasn't
expecting it all so i took my
orders and
showed up at uh
2nd battalion 12th special forces group
in tulsa oklahoma to begin my service
for your service as the
csm of 2nd battalion and uh i you and i
talked about it over breakfast but had
an interesting uh collision so to speak
i walked in to report to the battalion
commander and
he basically said what the hell are you
doing here
yeah welcome yeah welcome to 2nd
battalion but you're not you're not my
he actually told me you're not my csm uh
wilson hunts my csm and wilson hunt was
at the time as csm but
apparently i learned that at some point
in time one of the full-timers because
uh that
position had been occupied by somebody
for longer than it should have been
right uh that you know csm pulls a
four-year
tour tour duty yeah tour duty for four
years so you get in
he's gone then you do your four years
now during that time are there
deployments there uh yes there are some
deployments there uh
my gosh i didn't remember where they
were but uh we did have some we had some
interesting ones
that was later on well uh yeah yeah that
one wasn't uh
in fact that's that's where we did the
the uh
uh border thing right was during that 91
to 94.
and unfortunately in 1994
uh the 11th and 12th special forces
group were deactivated right uh combat
assignments were given to the national
guard by the pentagon
and
the army reserve
the reserve forces
became combat support and combat service
support units
so it was a black day
uh for 11th and 12th group soldiers uh
we did have a number in the oklahoma
area that we're able to get on and i i
don't i never do quite remember 19th and
20th right i know one of them was in
utah the headquarters and one was in
maryland right
i don't remember which one is which
but i do know that there was a unit one
of the companies
uh was in the mississippi area and so a
lot of the oklahoma guys did get on with
sf uh in mississippi but
nowhere could i find that anybody wanted
an e9
which isn't surprising i didn't mention
earlier that uh 12th group was kind of
somewhat of an oddity in in its uh
environment of of how far we reached
uh because as a csm i had to do a lot of
travel right uh and i said ache my
battalion headquarters in tulsa
a company was in
uh oklahoma city
b company was in el paso texas who
you'll love this one charlie company was
in san diego california all right and we
had a team strung out from uh oklahoma
all the way out to the west coast so wow
and charlie company's now up in orange
county oh is that where it is north of
san diego yeah they just we redesignate
it again ah darn that's interesting
so anyway that's uh i uh pulled the
stint there and then of course when it
deactivated i i actually uh ended up in
the 95th division and assisted in
setting up two brigade headquarters i
was a brigade csm 3rd brigade and 4th
brigade
and
eventually
served my time or you know did the time
that i could serve
in the reserves i actually went to in
2002 i got an assignment to bosnia
and uh was
in bosnia for a year all of 2002. so
what unit were you with then uh i was
with stabilization force bosnia and we
were located at camp boutonniere which
is in
just outside sarajevo bosnia
we had 34 nations
uh i was telling mentioned earlier that
i used to have a
meeting once a month with all sergeant
majors we would have a meeting with 32
country sergeant majors wow it was just
it was it was unbelievable and some of
them couldn't speak english and i
certainly couldn't like italians we had
we had
a rough part there so uh and so by that
time the conflict there with u.s
involvement u.n involvement that had
been going on for a year and a half two
years yeah several years okay yeah yeah
i think 98 maybe and you had the water
was there on base uh
gosh and what kind of missions there
you're supporting locals and training
locals well
the job of cj fotus then was looking for
uh
oh
the war criminal yes yes that was their
job in fact i got to go out with them a
couple of times and pull rear security
so
it was kind of fun indeed and got to
drop leaflets yeah it was all right uh
it uh i was trying to think started with
an h colonel
became the commanding general of special
forces
he had a brother
he and his brother were both they were
both lieutenant colonels i can't believe
i told you i'm terrible terrible i'm
sorry
but anyway
cj stott of then and then yeah he became
commanding general special forces uh
nice guy and
uh
uh the
sergeant major for cj sodium was murray
small and he was out of 19th or 20th i
can't remember a little bit short guy
but really nice guy but it was a good
year it was fascinating bosnia was a
fascinating area uh as i tell people
croatia is the place to go on the coast
indeed people never think about that no
no because you hear all the headlines
the conflict and
war criminal activity and just the
absolute hatred
between different religious factions
political factions there and the brutal
way of treating each other well and and
uh people ask well what's
beautiful country uh the thing you had
to be aware of though you had to stay on
the beaten path because they still
they're still saying that there's a
million land mines buried in bosnia
really yes though
so don't go stomping for them unless you
want a big bang
uh so
one thing i did while i was in bosnia i
[Music]
the contractor kbr
which was a subsidiary of halliburton
right and our uh department of defense
secretary at one time
uh he which he got a lot of heat for but
anyway i befriended them because they
were responsible for taking care of all
services
for
uh the americans that were in bosnia
and uh so i befriended a lot of them got
to know them and
they all said hey why don't you come
back and work for us
i thought well that'd be pretty
interesting and when you say taking care
of service that means everything from
food to portable latrines that include
weapons and ammo oh yes
any training no training no no not
training not training now they had uh
eagle base which was where the divisions
uh that was an all eagle base uh at
tuesday was an all-american base so
that's where the pers the personnel
basically responsible for
missions
in and around bosnia that's where they
were headquartered and it was strictly
all kbr
uh
and uh i mean they
they had it really nice it was really
nice when you went i would uh take the
general chopper blackhawk up to uh when
i needed to go up to eaglebase and uh
that was kind of neat too i've got many
pictures of me with two stars
on the on the seat covers behind me
but uh uh
it was uh
kbr had the food service at eagle base
right at bosnia i mean excuse me at
bootmere it was the uh the english or
the the uh the brits brits yeah yeah
wasn't very good
no of course not yeah but they're not
known for their food no no they're not
uh and i i will say that that i can
thankfully stay and i've still got i've
got a thing hanging in my office uh at
home
that uh do are we okay on time oh we're
fine okay yeah uh
uh
we
on bootmare we were allowed that's one
thing that everybody wanted to come to
bootmeer because it was a nato base
right you were allowed to drink alcohol
oh
eagle base
that was a no-no really so where did
they put c-h soda on bootmare
so a lot of the countries in
in most of the areas i mean except the
major buildings were made out of the the
the
conex type buildings and so uh my the
battalion commander of the of the
personnel
american personnel
uh
got together and we
uh
we started the first american bar on
camp butmere all right that's what that
was our legacy
uh this is after you got out
huh you're still in oh no i'm still in
yeah i've got many pictures of me in
uniform
in our bar we sold
uh good coal sarajevo beer and uh
it was a money maker it used to be the
german bars where everybody went we got
the american bar up and running
germans didn't have anybody to go to
it was great i it you had to see it it
was we called it sam's and it was
soldiers airmen marines and sailors very
good
but anyway that was a good time and uh i
i ended up going home
uh after my stamped uh year there and
due to some of a job situation i was
involved in at the time i figured it'd
be better if i left
so i decided that i was going to try kbr
so i contacted them
and did what they advised me to do you
know provide them they said
they provide me a date and so i went to
houston texas for a week and did their
orientation did their had to go through
their health exam
uh and
stood in line the last day to receive
orders thinking i was going to bosnia
and when i got mine handed to me i got
orders to go to amman jordan oh
so uh
jordan before and what's the time frame
here uh this is in let's see this was in
january of 03. oh january of 03.
so i uh get to a very nice hotel in
amman jordan and
in fact that year it snowed in oman
snowed in amman in the desert it was
unbelievable
so uh went there and then ended up
on a old
air force base
uh in jordan uh on the western near the
iraqi border
uh and it wasn't until i got there that
i knew really what was going on of
course they were building up for the
invasion of iran what else is new right
yeah i mean i meant do you land and get
the reality check i was i was start my
first job was as billeting supervisor
and i put 5 000 service members in tents
oh i had a
oh gosh
what's the green tractor uh
john deere john deere i had a john deere
gator yeah and so because there was high
accountability of these cots
right so i would meet the c5s that
landed with a bus
put them on the bus
carry them down to where all the tents
were and that's what kbr was doing they
were building these they were tents but
they had uh two before sides and doors
and then they added heating and uh and
uh
cooling units sure so uh we would put 12
to a tent
because they weren't going to be there
that long
so
i would then go down to this massive
gated
facility and
take my key open up the lock get in
pile uh 12 cots on the back of this
gator
latch uh tie it down and then off i'd go
to get to have them sign each
uh uh cot out uh it was it was amazing
so you go through that process and
you're there for the actual invasion
yeah
yes
yes uh in fact i was very fortunate
third battalion fifth group came in
uh uh on march the 17th i believe that
was the date uh when they went across
the demarcation line about three o'clock
in the morning i was standing with them
as they moved out i was wishing i was
with them but unfortunately i couldn't
do that so
uh
we started tearing down the camp after
that and in july i believe it was the
7th of july i flew into baghdad
and i was assigned as a camp manager of
a newly building camp
uh at alhilla
and as i was telling you and your wife
earlier uh
right where i where this place was
was the basically the start of
civilization tigers and euphrates river
came together the entire babel base you
could see from the air or at least
that's what they said it was right uh
the hanging gardens one of the wonders
of the world was there
uh if if the sunnis and shiites would
quit fighting
tourism would just be unbelievable
that's that right yeah the christian
uh error right there is the start of of
christianity basically and so
uh it was something to see we we
actually had a camp there uh that's
where i i'm
some of the guys that i
left on 17 march uh ran into there they
were up in one of the old palaces
uh and uh from third group uh excuse me
fifth group uh third battalion
and uh so i served in alhila then i went
to uh kabbalah
as camp manager there then i went to uh
the green zone in baghdad as a
operations manager for all of iraq uh
kbr
and then i got on with a little
security company because gosh they were
paying the most at that time indeed so
uh i did i actually did that's the word
we always hear about every guy i see
that's exactly the way you played the
game as a contractor sure went to the
greenest pastures so i went to this uh
uh
little uh they were actually uh out of
nebraska and they were an indian tribe
and they had this little contract in the
talk for doing uh
threat assessment for
uh the ambassador and his staff in other
words we
uh i worked night shifts when i worked
for them and we would take intel and and
help the uh folks plan their route for
the next day wherever they were going in
in baghdad or outside of baghdad and
take in all the threat assessments and
do that
so i did that for uh and there were
plenty of threats here oh yeah there was
lots of breaths there
uh it's uh
it was an amazing time i mean there was
lots of bad stuff and certainly i wasn't
involved in that being a be a contractor
most of the time uh i mean we had some
things happen that
uh had been nice too if you work for kbr
when you work for kbr you were not
allowed to have a weapon
really yeah because they were under
military they were under u.s
dod
contract
so
[Music]
your
security was the united states military
so and you couldn't drink alcohol either
so
your situational awareness had to be
really sharp yes you it certainly did i
always every time i got in a uh one of
the humvees uh i looked at what i
thought would be which guy or young
young kid uh when the [ __ ] hits the fan
he's gonna drop his weapon and i'm going
to get it
which one is it
so uh but anyway i did that uh uh
knight thing for a while and then i
actually worked for blackwater for about
three whole months
uh they weren't wild about sf guys at
all they were you know more the navy
seal guys but
uh i worked for three months with them
uh left to take another job with uh uh
what was the name of that well it was
out of framingham uh um
massachusetts that's what right
framingham massachusetts uh and they
actually built were in charge of
building the hard covers for
uh the defacts and through the through
the state department that's what's a
defect oh uh dining facilities sorry
about that yeah that's okay i forget i
know um
and over some large meeting types of
buildings when i was there they weren't
putting them over sleeping containers
but i understand that they
they eventually did that but it was it
was a system that looked like a pole
barn
uh and it went up over these tall
structures red iron
and the first layer was about three
inches thick of what of a tin and um
uh foam substance
and then below that was what they called
e-glass and it looked like a sheet of
plywood kinda
uh but honey uh it was honey color
honeycomb and it weighed 160 pounds of
sheet and they put two of those sheets
uh all over uh the top of the uh the
facility but uh i don't know two three
feet below
the the uh metal uh roof right and it
was designed the way it was designed it
was withstand up to 122 millimeter
rocket or mortar
the rocket or mortar would come through
and would hit the tin in the foam and
that would detonate it
and the uh e-glass would
deflect all of the fractals it worked so
that was a refinement of
uh building bunkers yes began in vietnam
and caisson
eight camps yeah so you have something
when the mortars and like exactly the
old sandbags you'd do three or four
thick
or more uh layers we did the same thing
in iraq uh
the contractors that i worked for we
didn't get e-glass
but uh so we would take the living
containers that we lived in and we would
put
three four
layers of sandbags uh
phil sandbags yes important yeah
so uh
that was the last company i worked for
but i worked for uh
uh them in basra uh the green zone and
in alhila so
and i came home uh in 08 i was i was
things were getting a little hairy i'd
uh
when i first went to basra
uh we started that project of for the
state department there and
you
you wouldn't spend five minutes outdoors
and all at once the rockets and mortars
start coming in on top everybody
so we had to stop construction
and so they eventually sent our crew to
baghdad so we went and worked there i
thought my last stint was back at basra
and
it's kind of funny because the i was
taking the
security manager of what i was i was
taking the place of another security
manager who was going home and so i
called him i said how's the how's the
enemy situation how's the rocket move oh
he said oh gosh it's almost done we we
haven't uh
we haven't had an attack in a couple of
weeks oh well that's great so i get down
there the first night i'm there we took
in 24 rounds
so i figured somebody's out there and
said hey wit's back let's let's let's
make him feel us our new targets here
let's make him welcome so uh i was
standing outside the hooch one
late one evening and a round came in and
there was a back hole back behind where
i was uh my sleeping container and took
out the backhoe blue shrapnel through my
sleeping container
uh and i didn't hit me thank god but uh
i i stood at that point i said yeah my
son's getting ready to start football i
think it's time for me to go home
no kidding so how many years at that
point five years that's what five years
is that right yeah
yeah it was interesting very interesting
and uh
i don't regret a bit of it yeah i
had a good time and it was it was a way
for me to stay
in contact involved with the military
i've never gotten that out of my blood
so when you go back does this where you
find that you that unique niche
and reserves and some of the federal law
where you've been doing work there
which is a fascinating
lesson learned this morning over
breakfast yeah uh
that's interesting because i you and i
talked a little bit about it at
breakfast and
i came back and a good friend of mine
just retired from the national guard and
took over as
the
paid employee because
uh of the employer support of the guard
and reserve the esgr and esgr is a
an office of the secretary of defense
under the secretary of defense i've
never heard that yeah it's weird it's
and it's all volunteer except uh every
state has in territory has an esg
organization
uh
and usually there's texas i think may
have three but most states have one
i don't know what they call it texas is
so big yeah
and california i think has probably the
same as texas yes but they have one
full-time person the rest of them are
all volunteers
so
the mission of esgr
is to educate
service members that's guard and reserve
and employers of the law yusira the
uniformed services employment
re-employment rights act
this is critical particularly these days
when so many reserved national guard
users
come about unbelievable
that's what i was doing saturday sure
we brief
the yucera
to service members and their spouses or
families
prior to them uh deploying and when they
come back
so this unit that i briefed on saturday
had been 10 months uh at guantanamo they
were an mp unit the national guard unit
uh so they'd been there for 10 months
so we talk about
what their responsibilities under the
law is and what the responsibilities the
employer is
like getting your job back uh if you
can't don't get the exact job then it's
equal pay and equal status what you left
your benefits remain if you're uh your
seniority if you left and you had five
years with your company and a year later
you come back you now have six years you
didn't lose that year
uh making sure your health
care starts again yada yada and if there
are issues if there is a problem that
that a service member has with his
employer
uh because of his service to the country
then he can
uh either call an 800 number or go
through our website www.esgr.bill
and submit a request for a case to be
filed with esgr and that time frame is
pretty tight yeah well it really is when
we get when that uh you know it's you
have to make it through washington
everybody oh gosh we'll never hear that
again well in this case
it's not true because they
pass that referral information on to the
state director of the state in which the
service member
works not necessarily liz but where they
work sure that's what's critical yeah so
um
we have 48 hours to contact that service
member and find out what's going on so
we can begin right to assist them
and
once we
have determined what the case is
then if it's termination or loss of pay
then we have seven days to resolve it
if it's any other item like i didn't get
my promotion i didn't get my benefits we
have 14.
now
in the state of tennessee right now and
i happen to be the state director of
ombudsman so i have 14 ombudsmen
throughout the state of tennessee that
work with me
we are about 85
of the time we resolve that problem
really if for some reason we can't in
other words we we'll go and we're we're
not taking sides of the service member
our job is to enter both sides that's
exactly right so what happened i mean
like if you find yourself
on one hand you got walmart and there's
a player going i've got a problem with
walmart
compared to on the other hand he got joe
bipp the ragman and his wife
running joe bipp's rag service
that could really get a little bit more
dicey for you in terms of trying to well
for the companies carrying that burden
you're exactly right uh you know we uh
a walmart if they lose an employee for a
year
uh and have to replace them with
somebody uh it's not big on their agenda
it's not going to affect them that much
but
joe blows welding service that has three
employees and you're going to take away
one of them for a year
that's rough and you've got all the
benefits and everything while they're
gone well
now
now that's not true
okay a a company can
decide to provide
health care can provide salary can do
other things for the service member
while they're gone the law doesn't
require them to do anything well is that
right yes so i'm learning something here
yourself well the law basically says
that uh when you return
you get your benefits back right now
again there are i don't think walmart uh
they may do some of them will pay their
complete salary while they're gone yeah
some of them will make the difference if
you're a e5 sure uh you know joe snuffy
uh making a not not a whole lot uh as an
e5 in the in the military and maybe he
was an executive at walmart you know
they'll make up the difference so but
that's up on them they do not have to do
anything other than that other than make
sure
that they can't terminate them while
they're gone uh we have a number of
situations number cases will work uh
they'll uh call
uh and or write the service members say
i'm sorry you you know you're not gonna
have your job when you get back yeah
yeah so that's where we intervene if we
aren't able to resolve it
then we give the service member the name
of the
uh
dol department of labor uh it's called
the dol vet they're the ones with the
hammer they're the ones with the hammer
you're exactly right so
most companies they don't want to hear
from the department of labor no so
that's us saying we're going to resolve
this we're going to help you resolve it
if we can't we have to turn it over the
department of labor we'll turn you loose
oh man so anyway it's it's it's a way
for us to stay involved with the
military but it's also a way to to give
back
uh to our country
indeed so it's like to me that sounds
like a major give back after uh how many
30
70 37 years yeah in the service and then
now how many years you've been doing
this uh i'm on 11 11 now yeah
so 37 11 that's about 48 in my book
yeah and it all began uh after a little
tour of duty with first group
and then a tour of duty and sog
running hatcher force missions and uh
that's
i never heard that before about a
hatchet force going out and then having
recon teams to sneak off
inserting on the most clandestine waves
like i said i don't know if that was the
only time or not like a stay-behind
mission yes you dropped them i believe
that's what they called it yeah if i
remember right now that you say that
stay behind yeah i don't know what i'm
talking about i'm guessing that sounds
right and it worked
so um
at this point in time sir uh would there
be any other little interesting tidbits
or closing thoughts here as we head down
the final trail to get you back on going
back to east tennessee your room
well i will say that uh
i've always felt
uh that i don't have a whole lot of
heroes
but all sog recon men are heroes to me
what they did
what they
uh experienced
uh the
unbelievable
courage that it took to do what they did
uh in the face of hundreds sometimes of
enemy is unbelievable and uh you guys
i'll never forget you i i just feel a
very small little part for being able to
one of those guys that helps support
that kind of thing well from one recon
guy to a hatchet force i said i never
wanted to do hatchet force duty because
you're big enough to go out and raise
hell for a little while but it's not
really big that you can go overrun an
enemy you draw a lot of attention a lot
of attention so do you so did you so
and uh so i think we're closing that
note sir and oh
you're also a member of the special
operations association
you've done some fundraising there with
a unique group the soa riders that's
exactly right i how soon we forget i i i
and i guess some reason uh director i
should say mr direct
uh
about uh let's see in 2019 i believe it
was probably around june july september
uh
our director of concern tom carroll
passed away unexpectedly yeah great man
had really done an unbelievable job of
maintaining the special operations
association writers which is a group of
uh motorcycle riders that meet once a
year
uh at some place in the united states
we uh usually well we always we always
uh have a ceremony at usually a vietnam
memorial uh in the area uh but uh it's
certainly a veterans memorial and we
honor the missing
from sog
both the
both the direct uh
guys and the support guys and right now
i believe the number's
131 if i remember right yeah total
numbers about 50 recon then 80 plus
aviators so the aviators include
everything from uh marine corps gunships
uh scarface for example
then we have uh
hundreds of units from the army 101st
commanceros
the uh
um
hornets green hornets the green horns
were down south yep primo and that's uh
of course that's air force people forget
that we actually had air force that was
the main support unit down south we had
the 195th down here yeah that made
historic uh runs and metal awards for
valor there
and then
across the fence of course cambodia you
couldn't have spads
but we had them and then fast movers but
all those that were that were now today
listed as missing in access so 131
and that number is part of the 1584
americans today from the war in vietnam
that is still formally listed as missing
in action that includes
the secret war where we have 131
and then uh for vietnam both north and
south cambodia
and
they got a couple from thailand and the
aviators and they got two or three and
somehow landed in china
but it's all part of the m.i.a story
that uh for now of course in the early
part of the vietnam war early 1970 when
you were there
it was the first time american
families
petitioned the enemy the communists of
north vietnam to treat our american pows
better
and since then we've had the national
league of pow mia families which is
advocated
both with the communists and the
american government to do more to bring
them home
and you're right getting back to the soa
riders
they have conducted fundraisers for over
a decade
and they've raised thousands of dollars
that donate to the soa
for
operation bright light for the
scholarship fund
where there are recon guys and
hashiforce members and other aviators
that are members of the soa now so they
are eligible for scholarships and the
bright light committee which is one
where they raise money to help a member
attend the reunion the annual reunions
of course last year
the china virus knocked us out of the
box yeah it certainly did they did a
zoom
which is a little different but the next
year
this year 20 2021
they'll be the soa reunion from 18 to
the 21st
or 22nd 22nd earth and then the athletes
and the same day the 22nd dsfa the
special forces association
will
have this union the first time
and they're doing a motorcycle run there
will be a motorcycle run and jocko
willink is billed as one of our guest
speakers for the sfa reunion so again
we'll wrap up on a positive note we
thank jocko for sponsoring us today
and thank you marcus for coming out of
your way to be our guest here thank you
for being asked absolutely as we close
we uh as always we pay homage to today's
service members
both for all of our armed services first
responders
any of our government officials that are
protecting our borders these days and uh
we continue to pray for them and um
the border patrol i think is earning its
pay amen under these new challenges
today but we pray for them all
and we'll close conclude by saying
god bless america amen
i want to thank marcus witt for being
with us today
and his story was different it's another
story
of men that served in song unique angles
and with me is my mystery
mystery technician
who today will go by tomas
we cannot receive reveal anything
further about the mystery man
but mystery man
what's your reaction to our command
sergeant major story
it's definitely uh
it was definitely a switch from the you
know all the guys we've done
previous to this with them being
involved in recon and yeah you know
so getting that different glimpse uh the
way the hit you know and you see the
admiration which is which is funny you
see that admiration that between uh mike
force and then to
to the the recce elements you know to
the rt's so
that's nice to see but i loved his
stories um
definitely liked the infill you know
uh how they did that and uh yeah i've
never heard that before for uh for sog
we had talked about up north and i know
there are some teams that did
stay behind
where they have two teams that would go
in
and then or like with elder barger once
they went in
with the team
and then they made it appear as though
they were extracted and they stayed
behind right and that i mean
makes perfect sense right they see you
coming in all these people
hopefully especially there the jungle so
thick can you really see how many people
yeah are you making estimations like oh
it looked like it was 50.
maybe maybe it was 30 but we can't
really tell so we'll say 50 just to be
on the heavy side well all of a sudden
later it's like well no maybe it was 30.
you know yeah but hey six guys just
dropped off of somewhere and they don't
know it i mean because you think about
all the noise you make in that size of
an element walking through and then if
you just all of a sudden slide off to
the side
lay down
and just wait
indeed indeed
wait until everything is gone and you
know you just stay there for a couple
hours or whatever you know hopefully
nobody walks on you but yeah you know if
you're there and you just split off and
now all of a sudden it's quiet and then
if the enemy moves through you can get
an assessment on that and then move on
through
well yeah one like and marcus like
everybody else we've talked to the
hardest thing is sometimes to get them
to talk about themselves yeah it it is
hard
they're so modest and down to earth
about it's kind of like well yeah i was
here i did that and yeah i was in iraq
we were there when they launched
and even the support element if you're
still there that's me i'm like going do
you know where i was the day they kicked
off
i was right there or you know something
like that i mean that moment in time
yeah but you
when you've done it as long as he has
what was it 40 48 years yeah and you
know dealing with the military one way
or another either being in
you know or being
a contractor working with it's like
you know after a while it's just you
know did i do anything what nah it
wasn't really even big yeah going
through all that time and service and
then
helping
the national guard troops and reserves
as such a vital volunteer position
definitely and 11 years
yeah i've done it for 11 years really
i didn't even know what it was but
it's a service that is
you know like we said very briefly
during the the podcast which was
you know so many thousands of our
americans have served
from the guard you know my stepson
went in with the reserves and got tasked
a third id got blown up with third id
thanks to some dumb ass lieutenant just
sent him out
and uh but yeah and what their full
benefits are
and working with the employers on issues
and then having a success rate of 85
percent
of the cases that come to them they get
them resolved before they go to
the heavy hammer yep and dol the
department of labor and i think a lot of
companies actually do
you know
they're not that way like uh
back in the day when i was with a
company um with verizon i'll say it they
uh
they were paying they paid mine and made
me whole and gave me benefits for three
years no kidding yeah while i was in uh
you know when i made the crossover and
was doing some stuff yeah they they were
literally paying me so i was still
receiving a military check and i was
receiving that check plus i was
receiving the benefits
um you know so which was really good i i
think that's an outstanding you know
solution
small businesses that's a hard pill to
swallow for a small business
you know
the fact that i think they would be more
willing to work with you you know i
can't see companies saying well i'm
sorry you were gone for a year so you're
fired it's like
you can't do that to these guys you know
they don't yeah they volunteered to join
this and yes they volunteered to go into
this and knowing they could deploy
but really you're gonna just you're
gonna kick them out you know it's i
guess i
you know i guess i could relate it to
like my dad's stories of when he came
back from vietnam and it's like i guess
it's the same thing hey you got drafted
you're going to vietnam and when you
come home everybody will hate you yes
it's like wait a minute i didn't go
there voluntarily
[Laughter]
you know or i did yeah but it's like
really
how why are we gonna look at that you
know these guys are out there uh you
guys were out there doing these things
you know
protecting our freedom
doing these missions that nobody else
would really ever want to do
you know or even in the right mind i
think there would be you know sigmund
freud would be sitting there going so
tell me a lot about your mother why
you'd want to do this
there's got to be something
but at the same point like it's good i
think that was a
his his story marcus's story is great uh
knowing that he went from
from sog oh yeah all the way through
iraq
isn't that something yeah
and then you know i and again i'm biased
because i've been a member of the soa
now for
30 plus years
and
the soa riders have been
one of the
great volunteer groups and they've done
those rides i mean we're talking major
donations thousands of dollars
and over the years probably now they're
over a hundred thousand dollars donated
that's awesome
if i'm free and june 9th i'm definitely
gonna yeah i'm gonna definitely try and
get out there to that ride up in
wisconsin up in wisconsin
see what it's like right amongst the
cheeseheads exactly
yeah i'll bring you back some cheese
they're not gonna ride during the
football season okay they know where
everybody's gonna be yeah they'll be in
the house or at the stadium indeed
there's no traffic jams on football day
yeah
all right any other five points here we
should cover with marcus
no i think uh i think that was good it
was it's nice to hear a different uh a
different side oh absolutely hatch
enforcement yeah
and yeah
about that and so in the weeks and
months ahead
we'll be
interviewing more sog men which we will
include hatchet force because there are
other hatchet force
teams
one of which we had in the book on the
ground where
the hatchet forces on the ground
made heavy contact for several days
everybody gets extracted
the last bird taking the team leader out
in this case is david gordon
and this was 69 october or september 69
helicopter gets shot down on distraction
was that the one on the into the river
no this was another one with um
where
the
uh lynn blackwood idaho went in and he
had a medic williams that was a strap
hanger incredible medic and he was great
in the jungle
and
captain ahn the king bee pilot inserted
them
at night and he's able to get that king
bee down so the team got on the ground
so lynn was there with hep sal the team
yeah for idaho and then the strap hacker
williams who was just a phenomenal medic
and they went in they found
the uh hatchet force team leader with a
broken back
so dave gordon they got him out
they never knew each other
he never knew who rescued him
lynn black in idaho did not know
who they had
rescued but he got him out
and
gosh it was over 30 years later
um
when we were working on the book
for on the ground you know dave gordon i
knew dave because he was a member of the
soa right he came up to me and goes you
know i was on a hatchet force i got shot
up really bad and
uh i was just uh i i didn't think we
were ever going to get out of here so
but this this recon team came in and
they pulled us out i never knew who it
was
i go really
and i was interviewing lynn
for the book for the second book went
back and we're talking to him i said you
know we had this hatchet for said didn't
you do a night bright light or something
like that i forget how the exact cover
so the bottom line was at the reunion
uh we got a picture in the book of lynn
meaning dave for the second time yeah
yeah the first idea is too dark they
couldn't see there's no facial
recognition or anything it's just like
get my broken me and my broken back out
of here and they did
and the medic mike uh i think my
williams is his last name i don't want
to miss
misspeak here off this spirit of mode he
went on to be a doctor
that's awesome just an amazing guy yeah
he's down texas somewhere now but i got
to give him a call but those are that's
another story that's a hatchet for a
story with a yeah with a unique spin to
it
so we will uh in closing we most
sincerely thank all of our service
members for defending our country
and lands foreign and near
and we thank all the first responders
and all of our federal agencies that are
working to protect our country god bless
america until next time
we're out